[Music]
go to sheldon in los angeles hi sheldon
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
um so basically i'm in a dilemma right
now um so i have i have a 2014
volkswagen jetta um it is financed uh it
is on a five-year finance uh apr is
nineteen percent
333. yes i'm paying 330 basically 334 a
month um on it so uh my engine basically
is is done i need a new engine um i
spoke to the mechanic so they are saying
the estimate was gonna be uh
it could be in the range of like five
thousand dollars
so on that note i am working part-time
uh and literally i know that's something
that i can i do not have at this moment
in time so my question is
should i sell the vehicle even though it
is finance should i sell a vehicle and
uh again been staying up on you know
what you were saying as far as you know
putting cash on a vehicle no i was
wondering should i do that or you know
what the other solution would be
what are you making what's your income
um right now i am at
i'll say
roughly a month is
is at 800 a month why are you not
working full-time
um at this moment in time that's what
i'm actually just working towards
working full-time why are you not
working why are you not working
full-time
uh i was working full-time i ended up
basically uh
getting something that could be better
potential as far as um benefits and all
that for myself as a full-time job that
i did have they didn't have benefits
yeah but your job sucks
800 bucks that's the poverty level
yes
you're starving to death man
you know if the other job you had was
bad this one's worse you need a
different job and you're not even
working full time
yeah why i um i'm in the process though
i did interview and all that and uh
could possibly have something full-time
um within a week oh god it's just
something that could be better yeah
actually so it's basically it's in the
company that i'm at um i work for the
city so i work for city working my way
up so it could possibly be a full-time
job that is within it needs to be a
full-time job by friday dude
i mean you're starving to death
um so you probably need to sell the car
as is
with the bad engine
and you're probably gonna have to borrow
some money to cover the difference
because you're in the hole but get
getting rid of a 19 car loan and get you
a thousand dollar hoopty to drive around
while you get yourself some good
employment
but uh man you're gonna get a job
you're starving
that's really and there's lots of jobs
out there